The seventh issue has to do with scaling and
here I mean scaling in the sense of the industry scaling up.
As the component entry grows and evolves, a raft of new questions arises.
For example, accounting.
How should component use be charged, particularly in
clients in which there are multiple components coming from different vendors.
With respect to deployment and
configuration, how are components packaged and how is configuration performed?
There's lots of packaging technologies out there such as RPM,
DMG, EPKG, Nix, and OSG.
What about disputes?
How do you deal with an unhappy customer if multiple components with
different vendors from different vendors are involved?
How about quality of service?
How are quality of service guarantees satisfied when multiple inde-,
independent components are used?
And then there's fault containment and error handling.
How do components detect and
contain faults when they are not in control, in overall control of execution?